J'ai été acceptée à l'Université Pepperdine,
et je suis revenue dans l'école où j'avais été élève
pour être assistante d'éducation spécialisée.
Alors je leur ai dit « Je veux être enseignante. »
Etonnés, ils m'ont dit : « Quoi ? Pourquoi ?
Pourquoi voudrais-tu faire ça ?»
J'ai donc commencé ma carrière d'enseignante
précisément dans même collège où j'avais été élève,
et je voulais vraiment essayer de sauver plus d'enfants
qui étaient tout comme moi.
Alors tous les ans, je partage mon expérience avec mes élèves,
parce qu'ils doivent savoir que tout le monde a une histoire,
tout le monde a un combat,
et tout le monde a besoin d'aide le long du chemin.
Et j'allais être leur aide le long du chemin.
En tant que prof débutante, j'ai créé l'opportunité.
Un jour, un gamin est arrivé dans mon cours
et il avait été poignardé la nuit précédente.
Je lui ai dit : « Il faut que tu ailles à l'hôpital,
à l'infirmerie scolaire, quelque part. »
Il m'a répondu : « Non madame, je n'y vais pas.
Il faut que je sois en cours parce qu'il faut que j'ai mon diplôme. »
Il savait que je n'allais pas le laisser être victime
de sa situation,
mais que nous allions aller de l'avant. et continuer d'avancer.
Et cette idée de créer un abri sûr pour nos enfants
et d'arriver à savoir exactement ce qu'ils vivaient,
arriver à connaître leurs familles, c'est ce que je voulais,
mais je ne pouvais pas le faire dans une école de 1 600 élèves,
avec des profs qui changeaient tous les ans.
Comment peut-on arriver à créer ces relations ?
Alors nous avons créé une nouvelle école.
Nous avons créé
l'Institut San Fernando de Médias Appliqués
Nous nous sommes assurés que nous étions toujours rattachés
à notre secteur scolaire pour le financement, pour le soutien,
Mais avec ça, nous allions gagner en liberté :
la liberté d'engager des enseignants
dont nous savions qu'ils allaient être efficaces ;
la liberté de contrôler le programme
pour que nous ne fassions pas la leçon 1.2 page 5, non ;
et la liberté de contrôler le budget,
de dépenser l'argent pour ce qui était important
pas pour ce que le secteur ou l'état nous imposait.
Nous voulions ces libertés.
Mais changer entièrement de modèle,
ça n'a pas été un parcours facile, et nous n'avons même pas fini.
Mais nous devions le faire.
Notre communauté mérite une nouvelle façon de faire les choses.
En tant que tout premier collège pilote
dans tout le secteur scolaire de Los Angeles,
vous imaginez l'opposition rencontrée.
C'était de la peur --
peur de, et bien, et si ils se trompaient ?
Oui, et si ils se trompaient ?
Mais, et si nous avions raison ?
Et nous avions raison
Et même si des profs étaient contre,
parce que nous employons des contrats à l'année --
si tu ne peux pas enseigner, ou tu ne veux pas enseigner,
tu n'as pas ta place dans mon école, avec mes élèves.
(Applaudissements)
Alors pour notre troisième année, où en sommes nous ?
Nous avons fait que l'école vaut la peine qu'on s'y rende tous les jours.
Nous faisons sentir à nos élèves qu'ils sont importants pour nous.
Nous rendons notre programme rigoureux et pertinent pour eux.
et ils utilisent toutes les technologies qui leur sont familières.
Portables, ordinateurs, tablettes -- tout ce à quoi vous pensez, ils l'ont.
Animations, logiciels, logiciels de montage vidéo, ils les ont tous.
Et parce que nous mettons ça en relation avec ce qu'ils font...
Par exemple, ils ont fait des campagnes d'intérêt public
pour la Cancer Society.
Elles ont été passées dans le réseau de tramway local.
Enseigner les éléments de persuasion,
il n'y a rien de plus réel.
Nos résultats aux examens d'État ont augmenté
de plus de 80 points depuis que nous sommes devenus notre propre école.
Mais cela a nécessité que tout le monde travaille ensemble,
enseignants et principaux en contrats à l'année,
travaillant plus, toujours plus que leurs heures contractuelles
sans compensation.
Et il faut un membre du comité de direction
qui va faire du lobbying pour vous et dire,
« Vous savez, le secteur essaye d'imposer ceci,
mais vous avez la liberté de faire autrement.»
Et il faut un centre des parents actif
qui n'est pas simplement là, montrant une présence chaque jour
mais qui fait partie de notre gouvernance,
prenant des décisions pour leurs enfants, nos enfants.
Parce que pourquoi nos élèves devraient aller
si loin de là où ils vivent ?
Ils méritent une école de qualité dans leur quartier,
une école dont ils peuvent dire avec fierté qu'ils appartiennent
et une école dont la communauté peut être fière également,
et ils ont besoin que les profs se battent pour eux chaque jour
et leur donnent le pouvoir d'aller plus loin que leur situation.
Parce qu'il est temps que des enfants comme moi
cessent d'être l'exception, et deviennent la norme.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)